good evening my fellow americans
tonight i'd like to talk to you about
where we are
as we mark one year since everything
stopped
because of this pandemic a year ago
were hit with a virus that was met with
silence
and spread unchecked denials for days
weeks then months that led to more
deaths
more infections more stress and more
loneliness
photos and videos from 2019
feel like they were taken in another era
the last vacation last birthday with
friends
the last holiday with extended family
while it was different for everyone
we all lost something a collective
suffering
a collective sacrifice a year filled
with the loss of life
and the loss of living for all of us
but in the loss we saw how much there
was to gain
in appreciation respect and gratitude
finding light in the darkness is a very
american thing to do in fact
it may be the most american thing we do
and that's what we've done we've seen
frontline and essential workers risking
their lives sometimes losing them
to save and help others researchers and
scientists
racing for a vaccine
and so many of you as hemingway wrote
being strong in all the broken places
i know it's been hard i truly know
as i've told you before i carry a card
in my pocket
with the number of americans who have
died
from covert to date it's on the back of
my schedule
as of now total deaths in america
527
726 that's more debts
than in world war one world war ii
the vietnam war and 9 11 combined
there were husbands wives sons and
daughters
grandparents friends neighbors young and
old
they leave behind loved ones unable to
truly grieve or to heal even to have a
funeral
but i'm also thinking about everyone
else who lost this past year
to natural causes by cruel fate of
accident or other disease
they too died alone they too leave
behind
loved ones who are hurting badly
you know you've often heard me say
before i talk about the longest walk
any parent can make is up a short flight
of stairs to his child's bedroom
to say i'm sorry i lost my job
i can't be here anymore like my dad told
me
when he lost his job in scranton
so many of you had to make that same
walk this past year
you lost your job you closed your
business
facing eviction homelessness hunger
a loss of control may be worst of all a
loss of hope
watching a generation of children who
may be set back up to a year or more
because they've not been in school
because of their loss of learning
it's the details of life that matter
most
and we miss those details the big
details on the small moments
weddings birthdays graduations
all the things that needed to happen but
didn't
the first date the family reunions
the sunday night rituals it's all
has exacted a terrible cost on the
psyche of so many of us
for we are fundamentally a people who
want to be with others
to talk to laugh to hug
to hold one another but this
virus has kept us apart and grandparents
haven't seen their children or
grandchildren parents
haven't seen their kids kids haven't
seen their friends
the things we used to do that always
filled us with joy
had become things we couldn't do and
broke our hearts
too often we've turned against one
another
a mask the easiest thing to do to save
lives
sometimes it divides us states
pitted against one another instead of
working with each other
vicious hate crimes against asian
americans
who've been attacked harassed blamed and
scapegoated
at this very moment so many of them are
fellow americans
they're on the front lines of this
pandemic trying to save lives
and still still they're forced to live
in fear
for their lives just walking down
streets in america
it's wrong it's un-american and it
must stop
look we know what we need to do to beat
this virus
tell the truth follow the scientists
and the science work together put trust
and faith in our government to fulfill
its most
important function which is protecting
the american people
no function more important we need to
remember the government isn't some
foreign force in the distant capital no
it's
us all of us we the people
for you and i that america thrives
when we give our hearts when we turn our
hands
to common purpose and right now my
friends
we're doing just that and i have to say
as your president i'm grateful to you
last summer i was in philadelphia and i
met a
small business owner a woman i asked her
i said
what do you need most never forget what
she said to me
she said looking behind the eyes she
said i
just want the truth the truth
just tell me the truth
think of that my fellow americans
you wrote nothing less than the truth
and for all of you asking when things
will get back to normal
here is the truth the only way to get
our lives back to get our economy back
on track
is to beat the virus you've been hearing
me say that for
while i was running and the last 50 days
i've been president
but this is one of the most complex
operations
we've under ever undertaken as a nation
in a long time
that's why i'm using every power i have
as president of the united states
to put us on a war footing to get the
job done
sounds like hyperbole but i mean it a
war footing
and thank god we're making some real
progress now
and my first full day in office i
outlined for you a comprehensive
strategy to beat this pandemic
we've spent every day since attempting
to carry it out
two months ago the country this country
didn't have
nearly enough vaccine supply to
vaccinate all or ever
near all of the american public
but soon we will we've been working with
vaccine manufacturers
pfizer moderna johnson and johnson to
manufacture and purchase hundreds of
millions of doses
of these three safe effective vaccines
and now at the direction and with the
assistance of my administration
johnson johnson is working together with
a competitor
merck to speed up and increase the
capacity
to manufacture new johnson and johnson
vaccine which
was one shot in fact just yesterday
i announced and i met with the ceos of
both companies i announced
our plan to buy an additional 100
million
doses of johnson and johnson vaccines
these two companies competitors have
come together for the good of the nation
and they should be applauded for it
it's truly a national effort just like
we saw during world war
ii now because all the work we've done
we'll have enough vaccine supply for all
adults in america by the end of may
that's months ahead of schedule and
we're mobilizing
thousands of vaccinators to put the
vaccine in one's arm
calling active duty military fema
retired doctors and nurses
administrators
and those to administer the shots
and we've been creating more places to
get the shots
we've made it possible for you to get a
vaccine in nearly
one any one of ten thousand pharmacies
across the country
just like you get your flu shot we're
also working with governors and mayors
in red states and blue states to set up
and support nearly 600
federally supported vaccination centers
that administers
hundreds of thousands of shots per day
you can drive up to a stadium or a large
parking lot
get your shot never leave your car and
drive home in less than an hour
we've been sending vaccines to hundreds
of community health centers
all across america located in
underserved areas
and we've been deploying and we will
deploy more mobile vehicles and pop-up
clinics
to meet you where you live so those who
are least able to get the vaccine are
able to get it
we continue to work on making at-home
testing available
and we've been focused on serving people
in the hardest-hit communities of this
pandemic
black latino native american and rural
communities
so what does all this add up to when i
took office 50 days ago
only 8 percent of the americans after
months
only 8 percent of those over the age of
65 have gotten their first vaccination
today that number is 65 percent
just 14 of americans
over the age of 75 50 50 days ago had
gotten their first shot
today that number is well over 70
percent
with new guidance from the centers for
disease control and prevention
the cdc that came out on monday
it means simply this millions and
millions of grandparents
who went months without being able to
hug their grandkids
can now do so and the more people are
fully vaccinated
the cd will continue to provide
additional guidance on what you can do
in the workplace
places of worship with your friends as
well as
travel when i came into office you may
recall
i set a goal that many of you said was
that kind of way
over the top i said i intended to get a
hundred million shots in people's arms
in my first hundred days in office
tonight i can say we're not only going
to meet that goal
we're going to beat that goal because
we're actually on track to reach this
goal of 100 million shots and arms on my
60th day in office
no other country in the world has done
this
none and i want to talk about the next
steps we're thinking about
first tonight i'm announcing that i will
direct
all states tribes and territories to
make
all adults people 18 and over
eligible to be vaccinated no later than
may 1.
let me say that again all adult
americans will be eligible to get a
vaccine
no later than may 1.
that's much earlier than expected let me
be clear
that doesn't mean everyone's going to
have that shot immediately but it means
you'll be able to get in line beginning
may 1.
every adult will eligible get their shot
and to do this
we're going to go from a million shots a
day that i promised in december
before i was sworn in to maintaining
beating our current pace of 2 million
shots a day
outpacing the rest of the world secondly
at the time when every adult is eligible
in may
we will launch with our partners new
tools to make it easier for you to find
the vaccine
and where to get the shot including a
new website that will help you
first find the place to get vaccinated
and the one
nearest you no more searching day and
night
for an appointment for you and your
loved ones
thirdly with the passage of the american
rescue plan
and i thank again the house and senate
for passing it
and my announcement last month of a plan
to vaccinate teachers
and school including bus drivers
we can accelerate massive nationwide
effort to reopen our schools
safely and meet my goal that i stated at
the same time about 100 million shots
of opening majority of k-8 schools
in my first hundred days in office
this is going to be the number one
priority of my new secretary of
education
miguel cardona fourth
in the coming weeks we will issue
further guidance
on what you can and cannot do once fully
vaccinated
to lessen the confusion to keep people
safe
and encourage more people to get
vaccinated
and finally fifth and maybe most
importantly
i promise i will do everything in my
power
i will not relent until we beat this
virus
but i need you the american people i
need you
i need every american to do their part
that's not hyperbole i need you i need
you to get vaccinated when it's your
turn and when you can find an
opportunity
and to help your family your friends
your neighbors
get vaccinated as well because here's
the point
[Music]
if we do all this if we do our part
if we do this together by july the 4th
there's a good chance
you your families and friends will be
able to get together in your backyard or
in your neighborhood
and have a cookout and a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together after this long
hard year that will make this
independence day
something truly special
where we not only mark our independence
as a nation
but we begin to mark our independence
from this virus
but to get there we can't let our guard
down
this fight is far from order from over
as i told the woman in pennsylvania
i'll tell you the truth a july 4th
with your loved ones is the goal
but a goal a lot can happen
conditions can change the scientists
have made clear
that things may get worse again there's
new variants of the virus spread
we've got work to do to ensure that
everyone has confidence in
the safety and effectiveness of all
three vaccines
so my message to you is this listen to
dr fauci
one most distinguished and trusted
voices in the world
he's assured us the vaccines are safe
they underwent rigorous scientific
review
i know they're safe vice president haron
harris and i know they're safe that's
why we got the vaccine
publicly in front of cameras so for the
world to see
so you could see us do it
the first lady the second gentleman also
got vaccinated
talk to your family friends your
neighbors the people you know best
who've gotten the vaccine
we need everyone to get vaccinated
we need everyone to keep washing their
hands
stay socially distanced and keep wearing
the mask
as recommended by the cdc
because even if we devote every resource
we have
beating this virus and getting back to
normal depends on
national unity and national unity isn't
just how politics
and politicians vote in washington what
the loudest voices say in cable or
online
unity is what we do together as fellow
americans because we don't stay vigilant
and the conditions change then we may
have to reinstate restrictions
to get back on track and please we don't
want to do that again
we've made so much progress this is not
the time to let up
just as we were emerging from a dark
winter
into a hopeful spring and summer is not
the time
to not stick with the rules
i'll close with this we've lost so much
over the last year
we've lost family and friends we've lost
businesses
and dreams we spent years building
we've lost time time with each other
and our children have lost so much time
with their friends
time with their schools no graduation
ceremonies just
says spring no graduations from college
high school
moving up ceremonies you know and
there's something else we lost
we lost faith in whether our government
and our democracy can deliver on really
hard things
for the american people but as i stand
here tonight
we're proving once again something i've
said time and time again until they're
probably tired of hearing me say it
i say to foreign leaders and domestic
alike
it's never ever a good bet to bet
against the american people
america is coming back
the development manufacturing
distribution of vaccines and record time
is a true miracle of science
it's one of the most extraordinary
achievements any country has ever
accomplished
we also just saw the perseverance rover
land on mars
stunning images of our dreams that are
now
reality another example of the
extraordinary american ingenuity
commitment and belief in
science and one another and today
i signed in the law the american rescue
plan
an historic piece of legislation to
deliver as immediate relief to millions
of people
includes one thousand four hundred
dollars in direct rescue checks
payments that means a typical family of
four
earning about a hundred and ten thousand
dollars will get checks for five
thousand six hundred dollars deposited
if they have direct deposit
or in a check a treasury check
it extends unemployment benefits it
helps small businesses it lowers health
care premiums for many
it provides food and nutrition keeps
families in their
homes and will cut child poverty in this
country in half
according to the experts and a fine
and it funds all the steps i've just
described
to beat the virus and create millions of
jobs
in the coming weeks and months i'll be
traveling along with the first lady the
vice president the second gentleman
members of my cabinet
to speak directly to you to tell you the
truth
about how the american rescue plan meets
the moment
and if it fails at any page i will
acknowledge that it failed
but it will not about how after
long dark years one whole year
there is hope and light of better days
ahead
if we all do our part this country will
be vaccinated soon
our economy will be on the mend our kids
will be back in school
and we'll have proven once again
that this country can do anything hard
things
big things important things
over a year ago no one could have
imagined
what we were about to go through
but now we're coming through it
it's a shared experience that binds us
together as a nation
we are bound together by the loss and
the pain of the days
that have gone by we're also bound
together by the hope
and the possibilities the days in front
of us
my fervent prayer for our country is
that after all we've been through
we'll come together as one people
one nation one america
i believe we can and we will
we're seizing this moment and history i
believe will record
we faced and overcame one of the
toughest and darkest periods in this
nation's history
darkest we've ever known i promise you
we'll come out stronger with a renewed
faith in ourselves
a renewed commitment to one another to
our communities into our country
this is the united states of america
and there's nothing nothing from the
bottom of my heart i believe this
there's
nothing we can't do when we do it
together
so god bless you all and please
god give solace to all those people who
lost someone
and may god protect our troops thank you
for taking the time to listen
i look forward to seeing you